all right story time you want story time
this is real uh one year for christmas
my brother got me a gift and the gift
was clearly a basket that was all
wrapped in wrapping paper with a bow on
it and i opened it
and in this basket was a bottle of
lotion
and the silence of the lamb's dvd
i love my brother
[Music]
silence of the land
so silence of the land well first of all
it's one of those movies where if i did
a video on silent throw the lambs
i would want it to be this big
psychological
deep dive like the greatest video i've
ever done
then i realized it's probably not gonna
be and i'm gonna have to be cool with
that
so in the world we're in talking about
movies you can talk about how a movie is
and how a movie feels i usually go with
how a movie feels so i'll just tell you
what i'd like about silence of the lambs
it's as simple as that so silence of the
lambs came out in 1991 i remember my 10
year old self was like oh
that movie looks creepy and now my very
adult grown up self was like yeah
that movie is creepy and what isn't
there to like about silence of the lambs
just look at it from the get-go
you have a relatable underdog
protagonist that you
instantly latch on to when you're
rooting for the stakes are high you know
they have to find this person who's been
kidnapped and if they don't that
person's gonna meet this very grisly end
that they've
told you about earlier on with pictures
and everything
it'll be bad also they gotta find the
creepy ass [ __ ] who took her
because dude
in terms of i'll talk about buffalo bill
later but yeah creepy's that's just a
word
he is an experience and you have this
other monster
who's this polite guy i suppose i should
talk about clary starling first because
she is the protagonist but since i'm on
the subject
let's talk about hannibal lecter for a
second this movie flipped the script
for me when i first saw it because
usually it's like you have monsters and
you have good guys and fbi finds the
monsters and that's that but now enter
hannibal lecter who at this point has
been in
cinema for decades so it's not new but
at the time
at least for me in my perspective it was
not that there hadn't been great
villains in movies before this
or even villains worth rooting for but
this
balance between monster and gentlemen i
hadn't seen not to this degree
not to this kind of degree that felt
this real he's one of the great villains
in cinematic history what makes him that
well
we root for him right we do i do every
time to my
detriment every time i watch silence of
the lambs i'm always rooting for
hannibal lecter but this movie sets me
up and
sets you up to do just that is actually
really brilliantly done
you hear about hannibal lecter early on
in this movie you've heard about the
heinous horrific things he's done
you know he's hannibal the cannibal you
know he eats people then when clarice is
on her way to meet him and interview him
for the first time you start hearing
these stories about how some
nurse removed his restraints he bit her
face it's
he sounds like a monster she's on this
long walk down to this
underground dungeon cell you're like
this guy's gonna look like killer croc
or some [ __ ]
what what is this polite gentleman guy
it's like the information you heard
about how monstrous this person is
and this seemingly polite well-mannered
person you see before you
you can't reconcile that it's like the
state of cognitive dissonance that just
hits your brain you're like i
i don't know what to say so until he's
an [ __ ] to clary starling i'll
benefit of the doubt and he just he
never is he's never a dick to clarice
in fact in his own way he defends her
against multiple migs his big thing is
he just does not like rude people and i
mean we've
worked customer service before who
doesn't hate dicks
now there's this hannibal lecter who
also hates douchebags
that's fine from there he's got you it's
just the movie just sets you up for that
it's amazing and then he starts talking
with her and then the alarm bells start
going off you're like okay i got you so
he is
very manipulative you can tell but
that's what this movie is this movie
watching silence of the lambs is a state
of constant alarm bells there's a very
predator versus prey thing going on in
this movie
in many situations including but not
limited to situations with hannibal
lecter
and you're never on the winning side of
that it's a thriller movie it's a
manhunt movie yes but it's also
it has it's horror which is what i
really liked about the series because
they took that concept and they
went forth with it and it kept up that
tradition and then there's buffalo bill
the creepy lotion in the basket guy from
silence of the land
what the [ __ ] ocean in the past this
guy is a nightmare he's the boogeyman in
the closet
he's the horror story in the recesses of
the minds
of all of us and he's a big part of what
makes silence of the lambs horror for me
once in a while in a movie there's that
villain that just
stands out as the creepiest son of a
[ __ ] of that decade that's buffalo
billy he's not like hannibal lecter
hannibal lecter is like the villain rock
star of silence of the lambs on account
of his intellect buffalo bill doesn't
have
that going for him buffalo bill just
makes your skin crawl and it's as simple
as that buffalo bill has no code of
conduct
he just has a preferred shirt size
that's what's gonna keep you from
getting
killed by him and that's just not enough
for him not to be creepy he's the
manifestation of the thing that scared
you as a kid
he's the reason the hair stands up on
the back of your neck when you walk to
your car
in a parking lot on a dark night
hannibal lecter shows that monsters can
be human
buffalo bill shows that humans can be
monsters
which is so much worse but also i like
clary
starling i like who she is she's this
underdog fbi trainee she just goes to
interview hannibal lecter once and she's
captivated by him yeah she
needs his help to solve this case that's
another thing i really loved about this
movie one of the many reasons
silence of the lambs is one of the great
manhunt movies of all time you have this
psycho you have hannibal actor who just
sees it all
he knows what's going on he knows how to
read this file and be like up yep
know exactly who this is it's not just
because he's smart it's because
he thinks like that you know he's got
the feeling this is just the most fun
he's had in years so he's gonna draw it
out he's just gonna play with him not
just for his own amusement not just to
draw it out because it's different than
his mundane ass day-to-day but also just
to show him who's the smartest guy in
the room but clary's just smart clever
and jody foster was amazing in the movie
i just like the dynamics and again there
may be a lot of elements in this movie
that are familiar to other manhunt
movies
but if that movie came out after silence
of the lambs
odds are silence of the lambs is a
reason why you can trace like a direct
correlation of evolution between silence
of the lambs and
that other manhunt movie that is also
great and even the end the climax of
this movie
the climax of this movie is anxiety
wrapped in fear this scene in the house
you can take all the anti-anxiety meds
you can muster you can take a horse
tranquilizer
your bpm still gonna get to about 120
while watching it just
makes your skin crawl in the end silence
of the lambs in terms of
manhunt movie it has everything it's a
and it moves lightning fast this is two
hour movie never drags it's the movie
when i was watching it this last time
when i was watching it today
i had to pee and i never left the movie
i could have positive it's not like
we're in a movie theater
no you just can't break that momentum it
never drags it always moves and it's a
movie that it was
probably the first movie that made me
question
what are monsters and made me realize
that monsters
well they're humans too but hannibal
actually just just being
flipped the script and anthony hopkins
crushes it which is great to look at
mads mikkelson hannah belecker anthony
hopkins hannibal lecter executed very
differently
but both those intellectual monster
types
that hannibal lecter needs to be they're
both amazing hannibal lecters just
in their way they don't cancel each
other out and i'm glad we have both of
them
in this universe it's smart drama great
thriller
amazing horror a perfect blend of all
those genres and actually one of the
three movies you know me i'm not one
where like oscars are the end-all be-all
but
it's one of three movies that ever won
the big five which is best picture
director screenplay actor and actress
southern through the lambs is one of
only three
another one of those three movies is
actually another favorite of mine
in which i learned everything i learned
about respecting authority
i learned from that film probably
shouldn't have been the case
but it is what it is so i'm not giving
you any new information on silence of
the lambs but it was groundbreaking when
it came out
and still amazing to watch today silence
of the lambs is
awesome tacular
right so the silence of the lambs have
you seen it what did you think about it
if you haven't
get on that [ __ ] let me just
think of it as me writing your
prescription like you just really
should watch it so what do you think of
silence of the lambs or what's another
manhunt movie that's a favorite of yours
and how do they compare whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you